hossa de classe il préfère les efforts
manuels en plaine est ici dans ce petit
village de saône et loire
ces adolescents se forment au métier
d'agent communal
un choix bien réfléchi pour eux il est
tranquille qu'on n'a pas toujours les
patrons derrière nous puis on fait plein
de choses quoi on peut passer bad et des
feuilles à poncer des trucs afin peindre
peut tout faire en une journée
j'aime bien sa une en dehors dans la
nature j'aime pas trop enfermé j'aime
bien travailler avec le bois les plantes
bientôt ils seront les hommes à tout
faire des communes de la région
alors afin d'être le plus efficace
possible
il faut tout apprendre y compris la
chimie vous avez en fait la molécule qui
est grâce ici est la molécule qui est
dans l'eau la formule théorème de
pythagore et de talent est indispensable
pour exercer leur futur métier
sur le coup on voit qu'il ya un
mouvement de recul mais trente secondes
après quand ils voient que pythagore se
résume à des des portails et que thales
se mesure à des finalement d aménagement
de combles
oui du sens oui mais bien sûr refaisons
du thales refaisons du pythagore et vous
avez vu que la même spontanément avant
pour faire la mesure l'inde donc moi je
suis ravi
attentif et motivés car certaines
communes ont déjà des marchés leur
directeur pour d'éventuelles embauches
pour remplacer les départs en retraite
c'est leur grande polyvalence qui attire
les mêmes qui sont capables de faire un
petit peu de maçonnerie de peinture de
plomberie d'électricité
et puis également de s'occuper des
activités qui sont propres à une commune
l'enjeu c'est embaucher des jeunes
et puis aussi de conserver des jeunes
sur notre territoire est de former des
jeunes qu'ils peuvent rencontrer des
difficultés scolaires et leur donner une
nouvelle chance dans un secteur où
beaucoup apprennent sur le tas
cette formation est quasi unique en
france les premiers élèves seront prêts
à travailler d'ici un an